great uh thanks everyone for coming to
the final tutorial session of the week
um today we have chloe hsu from berkeley
chloe is a phd student here advised by
jennifer liscarden and moes hart
and chloe has done a lot of work on
applying deep learning methods
to structural biology and she's going to
give us a tutorial on this
machine chloe's presenting over zoom i
will be moderating questions here so
i'll try to keep a lookout for audience
questions and
you can tell your question to me and
i'll repeat it over the mic uh and if
this doesn't work then we will take
questions uh after the talk
thank you
all right thank you preto yeah hi
everyone my name is chloe i'm really
sorry that i'm in berkeley right now but
tested positive for colbert so i have to
do um a remote talk
um can everyone hear my volume okay yes
okay
great um yeah and uh during this talk
please feel free to
ask questions and i hope the remote
setup works out okay for questions
so maybe before i jump into the talk a
little bit about my background i started
my research originally in theory and
complexity theory so it
it makes me very happy to
see everyone at silence and it has a
special place in my heart even though
i've moved on to biology
i
during my phd i switched from machine
learning theory to
start working on computational biology
especially using deep learning methods
for structural biology and protein
design so today i hope to give
maybe a mix of both i
plan to cover
the recent progress and
the what's going on right now in
the world of using machine learning for
biology but try to maybe also focus more
on the underlying assumptions or the
more mathematical parts of it
so the focus of today will be on
proteins and our structural biology but
before we get more focused on structural
biology or proteins i wanted to first
give a broader view of why we care about
these problems and
perhaps a higher level picture of
what are the
interesting
important questions in biology and why
do we care about those
so if we
look at ourselves
we're all humans and there's a lot going
on to keep us alive and functional there
are all these different systems
responsible for
getting air for
fighting
viruses or foreign invaders
and then for digestion for
for pumping out toxins through our
kidney and then through
our system so there's really a lot going
on and
while it's easy
in studying proteins or structural
biology to focus on particular molecules
the message here is that we are really
complex systems and there's a lot going
on and it's perhaps today not quite
possible to model
all of the complexities going on in
human biology through computational
models so
we have to do some object abstractions
and then focus on the parts that that
would be meaningful to model and we can
actually model today
there are all these systems and then if
we zoom in a little bit from the
global systems in human biology then in
every part of the system there's still a
lot going on
for example the picture shown here
is one region in the smalling intestine
so that's one small part of the entire
digestive system but if resuming then
there are all these different layers on
the small intestine and then if we
further zoom in to the wall of the
small intestine then we see these
further finer structures
on the surface of lean testing
okay so now we're zooming from the whole
body to a very particular part of it but
then there's still a lot and then
if we take one particular cell
on the intestinal wall here and zooming
and we see there's a whole nother world
in the cell and there all these
different parts in the cell responsible
for keeping the cell alive and
functional
and then if we further take one
particular part of the style and zooming
we see
okay there are actually so many
molecules working together even in the
particular subpart of the cell
and now
with structural biology the
the when people say structural biology
usually means studying protein
structures protein protein interactions
and the
3d structures of particular molecules
so in structural biology we're really
looking at only one very small thing at
a time we would be looking at let's say
this particular yellow thing here
or
this particular purple small molecule
dot over here so i think it's really
humbling to keep that in mind when
thinking about structural biology that
while structural biology has made a lot
a lot of progress and it's amazing that
the things that we're able to see now
but we're so very very far from seeing
the whole picture of what's going on in
human biology and it'll probably take a
lot more breakthroughs
to be able to have a fuller
understanding of how things actually all
fit together so i'd say there has been a
lot of exciting recent progress but
we're definitely still in the early days
in the grand scheme of things so now i
guess
what we're able to do is that we can
have a much better understanding of each
of these small parts in this really
colorful and complex picture but we're
still pretty far from understanding how
these different parts work together or
even
where each part is in the cell
this is not a real picture taken under a
microscope but rather an artistic
rendering it's still not possible today
to actually look at the cell through
imaging at the spine level and then see
which part goes well we just have an
overall idea of there are these
thousands of different proteins that
work together in the cell but we don't
actually know where they are and what
are exactly uh where they are and how
they exactly work with each other
so that's kind of the overall picture i
wanted to give as a background
if you think back to high school biology
you've probably heard about
central dogma where
dna
transcribes into rna and then gets
translated to protein
so i think
this is still very much true the
dna rna protein part but we have in
recent years
come to understand that there are
actually a lot more to this it's not
just the dna the genetic code that
determines how we are and how we
function
there are actually
many chemical modifications
on top of dna bases or rna bases or on
top of proteins so the
the perhaps at least when i was growing
up in middle school high school we were
taught that there are
a t c g four bases and then it's similar
to instead of a binary code of zero one
you have of these four letters as the
alphabet and the string and that
determines life
but we
over the past couple decades the
research community as a whole have made
a lot of discoveries outside of this
perhaps traditional representation of
biology and actually a lot of other
chemical modifications or
changes also affect things at a very
fundamental level
so
while
given all these caveats it is still very
much true that proteins are the main
work workhorse of biology there are
20 around 20 000 proteins in humans if
you think about it 20 000 is
perhaps
not a small number but not a huge number
so our whole body there are these 20 000
different proteins in different parts
doing everything to me that seems pretty
amazing that we can cover all these
diverse functions and we're all here and
alive with just 20 000 different basic
units of proteins doing all the
different tasks
uh so it's
yeah it to me it's really amazing that
at the basic level there
there are these different proteins doing
an incredibly diverse set of tasks to
keep us alive and here and
understanding how that works and
even beyond these naturally existing
proteins designing new proteins to
do
other tasks for therapeutic or
environmental applications that's really
exciting okay so that's my
introduction before getting to the
machine learning maybe i'll pause here
to see if there are any questions
[Music]
okay then i'll continue
i'm guessing a lot of you might have
heard in the news about alpha fold
making
a lot of progress on the cast protein
folding structure prediction benchmark i
will cover some of that today but we'll
also talk about some other recent
advances in
using machine learning for structural
biology
if we look at protein structures
they're
at the basic level made up of amino
acids there are around 20 different
amino acids that make up the building
blocks of amino acids if you go to cvs
or target and then you see a bottle that
says glutamine for example on it that's
one type of amino acid
now
these
linear chains of amino acids then get
shaped into what we call secondary
protein structures they could either be
these sheets beta sheets on the left or
they could form a helical structure
called alpha helices
and then these secondary structures and
further fold together into tertiary
protein structures
where
the
the sheets and the helices then twist
and turn to to form these structures so
when we hear about protein structure
prediction or let's say alpha fold what
it's doing is to go from this first
level of linear chains of amino acids to
the tertiary protein structure but it
actually doesn't end there
to perform most important functions
in humans or in life in general the
tertiary structure is not enough
proteins then aggregate into what we
call quaternary protein structure where
there are more than one chains of amino
acids forming together into largest
envoys
to perform protein functions so on the
left for example it's a
pretty
crazy
protein assembly where there
may be a hundred or dozens of protein
chains formed all together into this
pretty big ring this is from the
salmonella bacteria the same salmonella
that causes stomach issues and with this
entire
big protein structure it actually is
able to
allow the bacteria to swim or to move
this whole thing is a motor for the
bacteria that allows it to move
so as you can see um
there are so many chains together and
it's also not a static structure it's a
pretty dynamic structure that can
actually move and then
the outside of the ring allows it to
function like a motor and allows the
bacteria to move so
we we have made a lot of computational
advances in predicting the tertiary
structure and i would say now things
alpha fold to
the recent focus in the past couple
years have been moving above tertiary
structure to also use machine learning
and
other computational methods to predict
the protein assemblies the the higher
level
structure of how different protein
chains interact with each other and also
the dynamics of how these protein chains
move and perform dynamic tasks
now there
are a lot of proteins they're all made
up of the same amino acid building
blocks but they can be folded into very
very different shapes and just to give
an idea of how different the shapes
could be there are some examples here
for example the tube on the right
that's
made up of proteins and it could form
into this assembly of a very long tube
by stacking together the protein
building blocks one by one
or there are some
string like
formations where it's stacked
one over the other
or it could be
aggregated into a big ball with a lot of
different protein chains on the surface
these
these um protein structures over here
they're gathered over
the past
20 30 years in this data bank called the
protein data bank and without voting
data bank we wouldn't be able to do a
lot of the computational or machine
learning
um
advances on protein structure prediction
i think it's
often very
um easy to look at the whole data set
and then see okay we have
a hundred thousand different protein
structures in a data bank and each one
of them is just a data point but if you
think about the history of how these
protein structures are generated
usually back in the day if you resolve
one new protein structure that could be
a nature or science paper so
the the protein data bank of say
a hundred thousand different proteins
that's really a lot of work by a lot of
scientists resolving them one by one by
hand and under
thousands or maybe tens of thousands of
papers behind this entire data so it's a
really remarkable achievement of the
entire community to generate all this
structural data and also put it together
in an open source and
standardized format to allow the whole
community to use it and also do machine
learning on it
yeah the question so formally what does
predicting the structure mean does it
mean like predicting the 3d locations of
the individual amino acids that's the
question to repeat is formally what does
it mean to predict the structure does it
mean to predict the 3d locations of all
of the acids or something else
yeah that's right so the input of the
problem would be
a linear strain of the amino acids and
then the output would be 3d coordinates
for every amino acid so a finer level
detail here is that
within each amino acid there's
there are usually 10 or 20 different
atoms so the perhaps the more detailed
version of protein structure prediction
is
input
the string of amino acids and an output
20 different coordinates or however many
atoms there are let's say if there are
20 atoms in every amino acid then 20
different 3d coordinates for each each
of the atoms in each amino acid um
so
there yeah this has also progressed over
the years
earlier usually people
take some abstraction and then represent
each amino acid only as one dot or
a few atoms but
one of the
reason why alpha vote was so impressive
is that it's now able to have a finer
level prediction for all the atoms and
not just
the main atoms in every amino acid
another question
um i have sort of a related question is
like what does it mean to resolve one of
these by hand is there like a certain
like what does that look like
mathematically do you have to like solve
some giant system of equations or
something like that in order to figure
out how these structures fit together
yeah that's a really good question so
yeah it's not possible at least in my
understanding it's not possible to
do an experiment where we can directly
measure the 3d coordinates of every atom
one by one but rather the the two main
technologies for measuring the structure
is by x-ray crystallography or from
cryo-em
and in both cases we would
do let's say x-ray crystallography there
would be a bunch of
outputs from the experiments but then
the outputs of the experiments
need to be translated into the
the 3d coordinates of the protein based
on some equations or some underlying
assumption of how the 3d structure
translates to the
the direct measurements in x-ray
crystallography and it's usually not a
very trivial process there are
a lot of
um tech software packages designed to do
this but it's
a
pretty involved process to interpret the
x-ray crystallography or cryo-em data
and i'll also touch on this later one of
the most immediately exciting uses of
alpha fold is actually to help solve
x-ray crystallography or cryo-em data
because in some cases when it's a very
complicated protein structure for
example the one over here when there are
a lot of chains and a lot of things
interacting together then
it might be the case that we are able to
do the cryo-em or x-ray measurement but
we don't really know
how to interpret the data
or like find a solution of the 3d
structure that would satisfy
the experimental outputs
so one of the use cases for alpha food
right now that a lot of people are using
it for is to
generate predictions for the structure
and then use that as a basis to help
solve the experimental measurements
another question
i was just curious about the the data
make up of the um
is it like
yeah the ratio of like synthetic to
naturally occurring proteins in the
databank
it's mostly naturally occurring protein
and yeah actually that's a really good
question so one of the problems with the
protein data bank is that it's heavily
biased towards human proteins and
towards certain model organisms where
people study a lot
there are very there are some synthetic
proteins in protein data banks but it's
a very small fraction
and um
not and not all proteins can
very easily be crystallized so
there is also a bias in terms of what
kinds of proteins get put into protein
data bank
so for example
some of the proteins that are more
flexible and moves around a lot to
perform its functions those are harder
to crystallize and um
so there there are all these data biases
in closing data bank
but it's
it's pretty interesting that so far it
seems like those biases don't seem to
affect the performance of
the generalization of the machine
learning methods too much um definitely
there are there there are some
influences um from the biases maybe say
alpha 4 does perform better on human
proteins because it's seen more training
data but so far it seems to at least to
me it seems surprising how well it
generalizes to other things given the
bias in the training data
oh yeah another question
yeah how rigid or flexible is each amino
acid like you were talking about
identifying the location of each
atom an amino acid and i guess my naive
guess would be maybe that once you've
identified a few locations just the
rigidity of the amino acid might specify
the remaining ones but am i incorrect
about how rigid these things are
yeah that's also a good question thank
you um the it is rigid to some extent so
let's say even though there are 20 atoms
it won't have a full 20 degrees of
freedom but maybe it'll have
i'm not really sure about the exact
number let's say six degrees of freedom
so um
it yeah there are definitely some
uh
there there definitely is some rigidity
to help the production and um in alpha
volt even when it predicts all the atom
positions it also makes use of these
rigid transformations to help um help
learn the position of all the atoms but
the
the rigidity is not perfect so
um even if let's say let's reduce the 20
degrees of freedom to 60 degrees of
freedom it doesn't there are still some
relatively
minor
shifts shifting the position that could
happen so it's not fully rigid
any other questions
go ahead clay
cool yep these are all really great
questions thank you all
okay
so yeah um
yeah as um yeah that was a great
question first i go into this so yeah i
think one maybe this was
not as talked about in the media or in
in the public discussion but from
for people in structural biology i think
the most impactful use cases of alpha
flow so far is to interpret complex
experimental data
especially for cryo-em where
cryo-em is a newer relatively newer
technology for doing
[Music]
structure measurement compared to x-ray
crystallography but it has a lot of
advantages for example it allows people
to look at more dynamic pictures of
proteins and that helps us understand
the dynamics and how functions are
performed with the dynamics
but it could traditio i guess before
alpha fall came around
for a lot of the
more complex cryo-em
measurements it could take people months
to try to work out the math and solve
the cryo-em measurements but um
right now i mean alphavote is still not
perfect at this but at least it it could
be used as part of the pipeline to help
speed up that data interpretation
process by a lot
another
uh use of structure prediction is to
generate a lot of new data for predicted
structures and actually just last week
deeply released 200 million predicted
structures for
from alpha fault for all kinds of
organisms so that covers a much wider
basis of the structure universe not just
focused on human or e-coli structures
but it covers more organisms and give us
a fuller view of the
structural universe
i think these are pretty important
applications at least in my view
as to whether this will
help drug discovery immediately i think
it's perhaps
less clear-cut i think there will
definitely be
future applications that are very
impactful in drug discovery but so far
it seems like people haven't it's only
been a year so it's a really short time
but so far it's not as clear how it
would help drug discovery in the
traditional sense yet because for a lot
of the important drug targets people
often already have solved crystal
structures
but i'm sure
with alpha fold and with other newer
advances in machine learning we can
perhaps discover new targets and um
expanded the
conception of what drug discovery should
look like
so here is a video for the nuclear pore
this is
imaged under cryo-em and solved with the
help of alpha fold and you can see i'll
play this again
the pore can dynamically expand and
contract each different color in this
video represents a different protein
chain so it's a pretty big thing with a
lot of different protein chains
and to give a more visual sense of the
data scale
for protein sequences
so sequencing in biology most of data
comes from sequencing because dna
sequencing is one thing that we know how
to do very reliably and now cheaply
so
for all kinds of
biological experiments or measurements
usually people try to tie it in one way
or another back to sequencing because
that's one of the
few
ways we know how to generate large
quantities of data
maybe imaging microscopic imaging could
be another one but
really for all kinds of biological
measurements usually it's back to
sequencing
so sequencing is pretty easy to do and
there are billions of known protein
sequences from all kinds of organisms or
from all kinds of places
and compared to these billions of
non-protein sequences there are actually
very few experimentally determined
structures it covers
i would estimate around point one
percent of the entire sequence base and
it's
it has a lot of biases so it's not an
even sampling of the sequence space but
rather some particular corners of the
sequences
now with the new data generated from
predicted structures we're covering
around 200 milli
and
well maybe this is not the best picture
for it and these 200 million are chosen
more uniformly across the sequence space
so it's not just the absolute number
that matters but also that with new
predictive structures we're able to get
a more
uniform or broader picture of the
sequence space
okay uh maybe i'll pause the game here
to see if there are any questions and
since we're switching topics to protein
sequence models
any questions
um so this is i'm sure a super naive
question but um
thinking about like trying to synthesize
proteins to to do different things it
feels like a super hard task to like try
to design structures by figuring out
locations of all the like you know
microscopic elements
um
so i'm curious
you know like like you know if i'm
building like something like i don't
have to solve for like the molecules in
wood or something like that like they're
sort of higher level abstractions that i
know are like good substrates to use and
tweak and stuff like that so i guess i'm
curious like to what degree
you're learning like sort of reusable
motifs versus like every new design is
like a new problem where we have to
solve for all the microscopic if that
makes sense
yeah that's a great question too um i
have a slide here that might be yeah
maybe i'll skip ahead a little bit to
generative models so here is a video of
um
a machine learning diffusion model
generating a protein structure so it i
guess it already starts with some parts
of the structure but it's able to
actually predict all the remaining the
positions of all the remaining amino
acids to
somewhat reasonable accuracy so i guess
to the first question it is possible to
do it directly without the abstraction
today
um uh with diffusion models and also
with some other hallucination models so
there
there are ways i think we are at the
scale of protein structure data that we
can learn it amino acid by amino acid
without the abstraction
um so this is on the machine learning
side but on the
the protein
design side when uh
we actually make the protein thing lab i
would say today
or
yeah i would say today or at least a
couple years ago when people make
synthetized experimental proteins in lab
it's usually still
more basic building blocks
as you can see here they're
some common
motifs like the alpha helices
and in particular alpha helices are
the helical structures remember we
earlier talked about their these helical
structures or the beta sheet structures
the helical structures are
usually more stable and easier to design
de novo than the sheet structures so if
you look at the design proteins often
they have a lot of these helices so i
would say
the machine learning predictive power is
getting there to do the full
amino acid bioamino acid modeling but
based on currently what people have
synthesized so far it's still smaller
proteins and with a lot of these motifs
there's another question
so i wasn't wondering from new protein
structure prediction uh how confident
can you be in the model predictions and
yeah how can you say the model is right
yeah that's a great question
i would say one of the reason why people
use alpha 402 a lot is that it comes
with a confidence score and the
confidence score is pretty well
calibrated to me that was a pretty
surprising thing because i used to not
really trust
machine learning model confidence scores
or these um
i guess uncertainty measurements but um
based on
the the evidence so far it seems like
the confidence score that alpha vote
produces
is pretty well calibrated and it seems
to know where it's confident and where
it's not
any other questions
well thank you
okay so winding back so we talked about
protein structure prediction um beyond
protein structure prediction a lot of a
lot of the recent research activities
are also happening in protein sequence
modeling so the goal of protein sequence
modeling is to directly model the
distribution of protein sequences
without reasoning about 3d structures
and part of why this might be useful in
cases is that not all proteins have a
well-defined 3d structure there are also
intrinsically disordered proteins that
might be up to let's say 30 to 50
percent of the human proteome that
don't necessarily come with any protein
structure so that's why
when we think about proteins it's not
just the structure that matters the
protein sequence modeling is also an
equally important part in this
and there has been over the past two
three years a lot of work in
scaling up deep learning language models
for modeling protein sequences
so this is the plot here the scaling
plot here is from a recent paper last
month
i think this might be the biggest
protein sequence language model that
people train so far although it's
all happening so fast and there are a
lot of
industry players in this so it changes
probably every month so we can see that
in
in this example and also in general the
consensus so far seems to be that
larger
protein sequence language models do seem
to better we haven't really hit a scale
ceiling yet
so there are a number of industry groups
working on
scaling these models up more and more
um
so
the i guess when
when we talk about scaling and the
notion that scaling works here it's in
this direct measurement of perplexity
like if we scale up the model more then
that achieves a lower perplexity and
that means the model seems to model the
distribution better
but it hasn't quite translated into
direct applications i would say
the usually the the way people test
protein language models is that there is
the raw perplexity measurement that's on
a held out set that's pretty
straightforward and then there are these
downstream tasks or zero shot prediction
tasks where people
take the trained large language model
and then apply them for a bunch of
downstream zero shot prediction tasks
and it seems like even though scaling
does provide a lot of benefit for
for certain things
overall for some of the or maybe a lot
of the downstream tasks we see that
um there's maybe some kind of inherent
ceiling for the performance on the
downstream tasks and we don't really see
that much better and
much improved information performance
through scaling
part of that might be because
the there are some
inherent noise in the data measurement
and if there's uh noise in the data
measurement and the data sets are not
perfect to begin with then maybe it's
harder to see the model improvements in
those downstream tasks or it could be
that there is some kind of
not necessarily distribution shift but
um
or maybe it's also a form of
distribution like uh the the things that
the large language models are trying to
capture might not exactly be aligned
with what those data sets are measuring
exactly um
so because of these i would say that
scaling on protein language models seems
promising
so far by certain measurements but for
some of the downstream tasks such as
fitness prediction that people care
about there has been limited pretty
limited improvements
the main use cases for protein sequence
models is
one is to predict effects of genetic
mutations
i guess even though genetic mutations
happen at the nucleotide level but
because we can translate the nucleotides
into protein sequences we can then
interpret the mutational effects in
terms of how it affects the protein
function how that's one area in human
health where these models could be
applied to identify and interpret
effects of genetic mutations
another way these protein sequence
models could be used is to guide
sequence design choices in protein
engineering in protein engineering so
are multiple ways to design new proteins
we discussed earlier earlier briefly
about designing entirely new proteins
but the i i would say the more common
practice today is to start with a
protein that already almost does what we
want to do and then start with that to
modify parts of it to
do directed evolution on it or to mutate
certain parts to make it better
and with these
sequence models we can then perhaps
start with a sequence that already does
something close to what we wanted to do
and then use sequence models to generate
nearby sequences that might be better or
functional in different ways
we had a quick question
i just wanted to make sure and sorry if
i missed it but the
modeling there is just next amino acid
prediction that's right so it depends i
guess it's pretty similar to
nlp when people could do
next amino acid prediction in an auto
regressive way or it could be mass token
prediction in a bird style or it could
be
i think people have also applied other
losses or
training objectives so i would say
anything that could be done on natural
language could also be used for training
here
um what's the size of the data set in
this plot do you know yeah it's uh
billions of sequences billions okay cool
thanks
right okay so yeah as an example of
how it could
be used for scoring genetic mutations we
could start with a sequence and then
score the sequence likelihood and then
also score the sequence likelihood with
mutations included to compare the
sequence likelihood um usually on
average the assumption is that higher
likelihood sequences are supposedly
better
and in the protein engineering
application there is usually a feedback
loop or cycle where we start from
um something that kind of already is
closed and then generate a diverse
library
of sequences that are related but
different and these are candidate
sequences that we believe could be
good or could work
and then there would be a screening
round to gather the experimental data on
these
set of
library sequences
and then as a feedback loop we can
further design new sequences to go
through this
so the it's kind of similar to the
active learning framework but
one key difference here is that usually
biologists won't test one sequence at a
time but rather it's a lot more
efficient to test a large batch of
sequences at a time these could be
millions or tens of millions of
sequences in one round of testing
so it's uh there's also an interesting
perhaps
batched active learning problem here of
how do you actually do a good library
design to hedge the bets and then most
officially gather information about the
sequences so there has been over the
recent years some work on formulating
this protein engineering problem as an
active learning problem and proposing
algorithms accordingly
[Music]
okay yeah and then one interesting
question
i always think about for protein
language modeling is
so in natural language
processing
when we think about models like
gpt
it's
interactive in the sense that we can
give
prompts to the model that we understand
as humans and interact with the models
this way
and that has enabled a lot of the
applications for the language models but
for the protein sequence language models
it seems that
even
researchers don't really understand the
protein language necessarily so
the applications are perhaps
there could be perhaps even more
applications if we find a way to
somehow
more cleverly interact with the models
or prompt the models um this would maybe
require different
ways to train the model or represent the
data i haven't quite figured out what
makes sense there but that's one thing i
often think about how do we make these
models more interactive or
ways to
to
expand the models into
different tasks other than just making
mutations
all right so we've seen this yeah and
then in parallel to the protein sequence
language models that can generate
sequences there are also these
structural generative models that can
generate new structures for protein
design
this one that we just looked at as a
denoising diffusion model
and
our own work from
my internship last year at meta ai is
also looking at generative models for
protein design where we start with a
target protein 3d structure and then
design sequences for the structure so
for example this could be combined with
the diffusion model that maybe generate
the structure or parts of the structure
first and then we can generate a
sequence to satisfy the structure
there are also many other use cases for
this class of inverse body models that
we worked on
we covered protein design already
and then um
i want to talk a bit
more about
how these machine learning algorithms
work
so we talked about the protein data bank
data that's very important for enabling
machine learning applications
and another in
addition to protein data bank another
very important source of data for
biological applications is evolutionary
data so when we think about evolution
this is represented as an evolution tree
where
they're common ancestors for different
branches of life and then there's a
whole tree of evolution
and what evolutionary data means here is
that
we
measure
um sequences the genetic
sequences observe for different
organisms in this whole tree well
except that one problem is that we can
actually observe the whole tree because
the common ancestor is might
already be extinct so we can't measure
them so we got a snapshot of the
evolution but
by observing what's still alive today
and this is actually very rich
information because
evolution is this whole billions of
years of process of exploring a lot of
things that might work or might not work
and then the good things that worked
survived so
it's
a pretty rich data even though it's not
labeled necessarily but from observing
this whole distribution of what
sequences survive through evolution we
can learn a lot of
a lot about protein and also beyond
proteins other areas of biology
so as an example
there is this helicase protein that's
very important in
basic biological function
and on the left it's a copy of the
helicase protein in human so everyone
here we all have this protein
on the right hand side it's the helicase
protein
in thermophilic factor so if you go to
yellowstone national park and see the
hot springs you can find this protein
there and if you look at them they're
actually very similar
and this is through
millions or maybe
billions of years of evolution from the
bacteria to human but actually the
protein structure is very much still
roughly the same
however even though the structure looks
pretty similar the protein sequence has
evolved to be very different there are
only about 30 percent of amino acids
that are shared between the bacteria and
human
so here this is real that this sequences
here are real and there's the human
version of the helicase protein and the
bacterial version of it and you can see
that most of the positions have mutated
away but there are 30 of the positions
that stay the same
so from a machine learning perspective
what could we learn from these
mutations well one
easy thing to conclude from looking at
this is that
the 30
positions that did not mutate are
probably very important to be conserved
for the protein structure and the
protein function the the reason that
they stay the same is probably because
if they had changed and the bacteria
would have died or we would have died so
by looking at what's conserved and
what's not conserved we can
deduce a lot of information about what's
critical for the protein function and so
on
and this is
this alignment is usually called a
multiple sequence alignment here i'm
only showing two sequences but in a lot
of other use cases there could be
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
sequences in this multiple sequence
alignment matrix
and if you uh
think about what we could do on the data
one thing is that
we could
look at the
learned sequence density on these
sequences for example here we see some
clusters of proteins may be closer
together in clusters but there are some
further sparse areas
and the higher density areas where we're
more likely to observe sequences means
that they
are more likely to contain functional
proteins
even before deep learning came about
there were a lot of simple models now
evolutionary that also work pretty well
for example hmms or these markov random
fields pairwise linear models
they all function i would say in the
same principle as the deep learning
methods today which is to model the
distribution of sequences and have the
assumption that higher sequence
likelihood through evolution means more
likely functional proteins
today instead of the hmms or
markov random fields we can now also
replace them with deep learning models
and the main advantage of doing so as
opposed to using the hmns is that there
is less restriction on the protein
length or
there's no need to enforce this multiple
sequence alignment we can
have the same model learn the whole
sequence distribution regardless of the
sequence length or the alignment and
this allows us to do the same model on a
lot of different families of proteins
together
it may be
in reality a mixture model with um
i guess one way to think about it is
that it could be a mixture model of a
lot of hmns
but or maybe it could learn some
generalized rules from all these
families together at the same time
um
so in that was for protein sequence
modeling but even in structural
prediction in alpha 4 2 it relies pretty
heavily on the evolutionary data so as
the input of alpha flow 2 it looks at
this multiple sequence alignment for
example the same one shown here so this
would be the input of alpha volt 2 if we
want to predict the structure of this
helicase
and by looking at the
multiple sequence alignment as input the
model can then extract structural
information from the multiple sequence
alignment
and this evolutionary information is
very critical for alphavote also based
on studies
essentially if we don't
link this evolutionary information to
alpha volt and only give a single
sequence then it works much much worse
so the
um
yeah i would say in a lot of different
protein machine learning applications
evolutionary information is really a
foundation for a lot of the models
but it's for our fault too it's not only
the evolutionary information it also
uses structure modules to iteratively
refine the structure even after
extracting the evolutionary information
so the evolutionary information is not
perfect and then the model also tries to
learn some physics principles to refine
the structure here's an example of how
it iterated so
uh i'll start at the beginning so
the model has two stages first it
already does this evil former to look at
the evolutionary information and
afterwards it has a iterative refinement
on the structure so this is the
iterative refinement part
you can see that initially the
predictions are not quite right but
through iterative refinement it's able
to
adjust it better and better initially
there are some more global adjustments
but then towards the end it's more local
adjustments
i think that this was a main innovation
from alpha food for doing the recycling
iterative refinement and it turns out
that perhaps it's much easier for the
model to learn how to iteratively refine
a structure rather than directly predict
the right one right away and often it
takes
dozens of iterative refinements for the
model to get to a good structure
sometimes in more complex proteins it
might be even more cycles of iterative
refinement
this is the ablation study on alpha fold
you can see that
a lot of the other things maybe don't
matter so much
but the um
the recycling which is iterative
refinement is pretty important and there
are also
some other innovations that are pretty
important in terms of how they do the
attention and the structure module but i
won't be able to get to the details of
those today
um
i assume the multiple species alignment
is between different species if do
people do alignments you know like if i
have like hawks family or you know some
repeated
uh gene with like in a single species i
could imagine like doing alignments of
the common proteins
yeah i think people also do so yeah
there's multiple sequential across
species but also let's say if i want to
study
fine or
polymorphism within the human population
then it's also
the same idea also makes sense to do the
alignment within human sequences
that makes sense but i guess you could
also do it within it like even within a
single human i guess right where like
right yeah yeah
yeah so for a single human usually we
for example for the helicase protein
there's only one copy so for a single
human the protein would all be the same
but for some other things like people
study cancer mutations
because in cancer a lot of the
genetic mutations are happening or in
immune systems where there is a lot of
mutation then that could make sense
within that single humor
like keep talking a second but even even
when we say like oh there's only a
single protein
i guess i'm curious you know like
[Music]
like
to what degree is like the history of
evolution within like a human like you
know if i have two proteins which maybe
we call different now but they came from
like duplicating and then modifying some
common interest or something like that
is there like yeah can i use this like
sort of common evolutionary history to
like extract
more conservation information or is that
um
is that it's like not it's not that much
of those examples
i haven't seen that being used but maybe
in some cases it might make sense yeah
any other questions
what do you mean by recycling in alpha
photos architecture
oh so
uh
okay it doesn't show
here within the structure module so here
um you do see recycling at the bottom so
it
after making one prediction of the
structure the structure then is also fed
as an input to the model to get a second
iteration of the structure and then
again so there's the msa input that's
always the same
and then through the model there's one
candidate structure and then this
candidate structure and also the
confidence scores get fed back into the
model as input okay got it thank you
also have another question how can we
generate an evolutionary set of mutated
sequences would that involve using say
like
multiple sequence alignment like msa
transformer or maybe inverse folding
could they be used for this
uh
could you clarify a little bit with um
maybe like for example like generating
like an evolutionary set of
mutated sequences for example if i've
got like the older sequences and then
like what could be the next variant if
it's yeah
so they're yeah they're actually yeah
these models could be used for doing
that based on taking gradients in the
likelihood and there was a pretty
interesting paper last year called
evolutionary velocity
that uses language models to
extract or map out the evolutionary
history of
viruses hope you got it thank you uh
sorry can i ask another question um is
there any way to detect mutation
hotspots given
if you've got say like an illusionary
set of sequences
yeah from multiple sequence alignment
for example we can see which positions
are uh mutated most frequently and then
for new
uh proteins that we don't have multiple
sequence alignments for these language
models or structure based language
models such as the inverse body models
can also be used to score where the
mutational hot spots are
okay got it and we could just mutate the
spots further say using like mask
language modeling or span masking yeah
so one last question i'm so sorry but uh
but uh how can we evaluate the mutations
for their fitness prediction that you
mentioned
so for the if we're using a model to
evaluate the mutations then it would be
to look at the likelihood of the
sequence under the model with or without
mutation
um and if we're doing that in lab then
people synthesize protein sequences with
those mutations and then measure that
together with
a controlled lab
got it thank you
cool thank you
okay so in the interest of time i think
we're already
uh over time uh we have we have about 10
minutes
um maybe i'll also let you pause for
future questions uh whenever you want to
uh to use the ten minutes as
you like
okay thank you no that's perfect i have
um the last section i think 10 minutes
is
just about the right time so
we talked about uh how some of those
models work and the applications and i
wanted to end with two maybe more
open-ended questions
for
all of us to think about
when is this question of
search and learn
versus learning a universal model so
we've seen that in the case of
using a multiple sequence alignment we
are
looking at the whole database of
evolutionary sequences but then only
grabbing the ones that are relevant
for the target protein that we want to
predict structures for or want to model
so the
yeah the visuals here are showing let's
say we have this gray gray circle is the
billions of sequences that we have in
the whole database now in in the case of
alpha fold or other msa based method
we do the search first and grab
a small set of in the hundreds or
thousands of related sequences and then
we learn
a local
model in some sense based on these
hundreds or thousands of sequences
and in contrast to this search and then
learn approach the large language model
approach
tries to learn a universal protein
language model on this whole data set
and then on top of that learn
representation it could also be used for
doing structure prediction
there is some recent work this year
after alpha fall 2 was published using
these
language models without any multiple
sequence alignments for doing structure
prediction it's still hard to say how
the results compare exactly but there
has been a lot of recent progress on
that as well so there is an interesting
question of
which one is the
more efficient way to go about
this is it better to
search and then learn a local model or
is it better to just have the model
learn and
reason about the whole thing it's still
not very clear to me in terms of the
computational time the search
actually is often a computational
bottleneck for example
in alpha fold or usually any msa
multiple sequence alignment based method
the search to grab these related
multiple sequences is actually the main
computational bottleneck and takes most
of the time
in the
protein language modeling approach since
it gets to
skip this search part
the inference time is much faster
because it doesn't need to do the search
but maybe in compensation for that the
training time might take longer but it
it largely reduces the inference time
and makes it faster to use so i think
that's an interesting
comparison and contrast between the two
so far i guess the best performing
models are still msa based but it does
have limitations and it's the searches
the other comparison or question that
people
often think about
um
is whether
these language models are effectively
also doing search i guess in a way these
language models have let's say the model
already has billions of parameters and
then they're trained on
these databases or billions of sequences
that maybe the model can somehow
actually
memorize a lot of these sequences and
then implicitly do a search
internally in the model
there is
i guess within the biology the machine
learning for biology community people
haven't
really crystallized this or tested this
in a way but maybe for people who have
thought about this more in other
contexts i would be curious to know if
you have any idea of how to test this
hypothesis of
is this model implicitly doing the
search and then maybe it also has some
kind of implicit msa while doing the
reasoning for doing the structure
prediction or other tasks or is it
actually learning something completely
different and
we
we can't quite think about it
in this memorization and search paradigm
so i would say to me these are both open
questions
that
um a lot of people think about or have
hypothesis or guesses for but they seem
at least
for now hard to
test in a rigorous way and examine
okay yeah
that's about it so end here um and see
if there are any more questions
thank you
thanks
we have some time for questions jamie
is there any similarity between the the
iterative refinement that you showed
that alpha folds um
takes in in in approaching the final
structure and the actual folding process
that takes place physically in time with
proteins
no i don't think so
yeah i don't think a protein could start
with this
aggregated
part yeah but maybe towards the end it
might
model some of the physical forces on the
protein so yeah
at least there hasn't been any evidence
that it it follows the floating process
[Music]
should we understand the physical
process as a sort of like energy
minimization
so yeah maybe yeah a good that's a good
question i think
i'm not a
i'm not super familiar with how protein
folding
um actually
follows an energy minimization or not um
so
maybe i'm not in the best position to
answer this i think there's some aspect
of energy minimization in it but um in
protein folding in cells there
it comes out of the ribosome which is
another protein so it might also be
affected by other things that's not just
purely the energy of the protein itself
any other questions
i had a sort of basic question
um do you know if we when we train these
sequence models just on the protein
sequences
do we know if the
representations that they learn are
meaningful in uh
for any sort of higher structure like do
we know if the sequence models cluster
proteins by structure or function or
something like that yeah that's a good
question for the protein sequence models
then it actually yeah it's pretty
interesting they are
they can also be used to do protein
structure prediction even without
further training but that the
performance is not super good um and um
in the
existing papers it's people look at the
attention maps for the protein sequence
models and then the attention maps
seem to correspond to protein structure
so
i'm not sure as sure about the
representation for the sequences
themselves but it seems like at least in
the attention map that shows the model
does do some level of structural
reasoning
curious about whether people augment the
like uh next amino acid prediction with
like just throw in as much extra info as
you can like conservation and structure
you can imagine just like doing that all
as the next you know
next token prediction
i haven't seen any work doing that but
that could be interesting
yeah right now it's usually
at least like what people have done so
far is usually just on protein sequences
themselves
um although i guess maybe one contrast
is
the
inverse holding model here starts with
the protein structure and then
model the sequences through next amino
acid prediction
so when we compare this with
just doing the next amino acid
prediction without the structure as
input to the encoder
the performance is much much better with
the structure the perplexity here is
around four and in contrast if we only
look at the sequence without the
structure the perplexity is usually
around 11 or 10. so from 10 to four it's
a pretty big reduction in perplexity the
structure does give a lot of information
one more question
hi yeah say a great talk thank you
so
when when the when the polypeptide chain
comes out of the
of the of the ribosome
in many cases there are there are other
proteins saperons that help
the the protein foldings i was wondering
if
uh incorporating also the
sub sufferance
structure in the model could help i know
is this related with the previous
question with one of the previews yeah i
think that's a really great idea i
haven't thought about that but i like
this idea a lot and maybe doing the
recycling perhaps rather than just doing
the recycling on its own we could
include the chaperones during this
recycling somehow and uh jointly model
them i think that's a great idea
thanks a lot for the questions uh we're
out of time now so let's thank our
speaker again
thank you
yeah it's a lot more fun with all the
questions so thank you all for all the
questions and thank you for your time
thanks um and thanks everyone for
showing up to this simon's week in
summer school i'll invite peter up here
to wrap us up
yeah let me add my thanks thanks
everyone for being here um it's been a
lot of really interesting discussions
throughout the week
um and a big thank you to all the all
the speakers we've had uh amazing lineup
and they did a fantastic job and
especially thank you to the organizers
so uh uh nutty sribro suriya gonosika
um and
especially uh preetum
yangtak and and spencer
um uh hugely energetic hugely thoughtful
in putting together the program for this
week the the tutorial
um talks the the research talks uh it's
all been really fantastic and i've been
sort of in the background seeing the
discussions have been going on and uh
you know these folks really were um the
driving force behind this week i think
it was really excellent so big thank you
to to all of those
it's also 2